7 au pied de leur hôtel que le deportivo
voltaire ferretti champions ti du
nicaragua a improvisé son ultime
entraînement avant le match de 16e de
finale de la ligue des champions de la
concacaf face au club franciscain
championne martinique qu'ils prennent
très au sérieux
nous savons que ce sera assez compliqué
nous allons tout faire pour mettre en
place notre plan de jeu et c'est de
sortir un résultat positif de ce match
face aux amateurs francis calais
professionnels nicaraguayen comptent
bien ne rien lâcher
il coûte surtout sur leur collectif et
leur détermination à remporter cette
compétition
notre objectif est celui de tous mes
coéquipiers et de montrer un bon niveau
pour mettre en å uvre du nicaragua et le
nom de notre club water ferritine nous
allons travailler et essayer d'aller
étape par étape pour essayer d'obtenir
de grandes choses pour notre pays
qualification en deux parties pour ce
16e de finale puisque après le match ce
soir 20 heures au stade pierre aliker
martiniquais et nicaraguayens ont rendez
vous le 8 août prochain pour le match
retour au costa rica
[Applaudissements]